raus aus dem Bellevue Frank-Walter
Steinmeier macht den Vorort Besuch zu
seinem Markenzeichen wir treffen den
Bundespräsidenten im Aartal und sprechen
über die Katastrophe von 21 den Zustand
des Landes den Krieg in der Ukraine und
die Fußball-WM der Frauen herzlich
willkommen zum ersten sommerinterview
des Jahres
[Musik]
Herr Bundespräsident das könnte ein
echtes sommerinterview werden wir können
dazu danke schön dass Sie die Zeit
nehmen wir sind im Ahrtal nächste Woche
jährt sich hier zum zweiten Mal schon
die furchtbare Katastrophe 135 Menschen
sind hier gestorben was ist ihr Eindruck
wenn Sie hier mit den Menschen sprechen
sie sind ja jetzt hier vor Ort viele
sind schon obwohl so viel passiert doch
müde frustriert auch teilweise wütend
auf die Politik das ist nicht noch
stärker voran geht und angetrieben wird
also erstens bin ich Froschhausen dass
wir uns hier treffen in der Tat wir
haben die Bilder und Nachrichten aus
Jena
Nacht der Flut nicht vergessen die
vielen Toten die zerstörten Häuser das
Maß der Zerstörung in jenen Tagen es war
eigentlich Jahrhundertflut wie wir
gesagt haben und deshalb darf es nicht
erstaunen dass zwei Jahre später einige
Spuren dieser Flut noch sichtbar sind
unabhängig davon wir fahren hier durch
Orte in denen dankeszeichen aufgehängt
worden sind an die Helfer aus allen
Regionen unseres Landes und ich kann
diese Dankbarkeit auch immer nur äußern
ich bin beeindruckt von dem was
innerhalb dieser zwei Jahre wieder
aufgebaut worden ist und deshalb ist
meine Botschaft an alle außerhalb der
Art kommt zurück hierher geht wandern
genießt den Wein das gute Essen das ist
das was man in dieser Situation für die
a wirklich tun kann die Aufarbeitung
läuft ja noch warum es eben so viele
Tote geben muss es hat Rücktritte
gegeben inzwischen und mancher hier
erwartet auch mal sowas wie eine
Entschuldigung der politischen
Verantwortlichen vielleicht dafür dass
man die Gefahr so unterschätzt hat ist
es dafür an der Zeit ich weiß gar nicht
ob es jetzt an der Zeit ist ich bin
jetzt zum vierten Mal seit der
Flutkatastrophe hier ich habe an vielen
Veranstaltungen teilgenommen selten habe
ich so viel Empathie von
verantwortlichen Politikern der
kommunalen Ebene wieder Landesebene
erlebt die ihre Trauer ihre
Betroffenheit geäußert haben ihre
Empathie aber auch den Willen und darauf
kommt es doch jetzt an zu lernen aus
dieser Flutkatastrophe und die
entscheidende Botschaft aus der
Flutkatastrophe ist doch der Kampf gegen
den Klimawandel ist notwendig wir
schützen am Ende nicht nur das Klima
sondern wir schützen uns selbst und
diese Botschaft ist hoffentlich
verstanden ein heißer Tag im Ahrtal wir
reden jetzt weiter über Verantwortung
auch von Politik und können das tun hier
am alten Bahnhof von mayschoss da wird
in wenigen Wochen auch wieder nagelneu
ein lokale eröffnet auch diesen Bahnhof
habe ich im letzten Jahr noch als Ruine
gesehen den Inhaber auf der anderen
Seite mit einiger Verzweiflung in den
Augen getroffen und ich freue mich dass
dieser Bahnhof als Gaststätte in
nächsten Monat wieder eröffnet wird
Herr Bundespräsident die Berliner
Politik hat sich in den letzten Tagen
ein ziemlich marodes Bild geleistet und
sich mit Schreierei und Pöbelei am
Freitag im Bundestag in die Sommerpause
verabschiedet zuvor kam noch Karlsruhe
hat der ampelregierung die rote Karte
gezeigt in Sachen heizungsgesetz wie
viel Vertrauen wird er gerade verspielt
in Sachen Glaubwürdigkeit
Handlungsfähigkeit von Politik wir haben
Veränderungen in der politischen
Landschaft zumindest wenn wir auf die
gegenwärtigen Umfragen schauen und in
der Tat mit Blick nur auf die Umfragen
zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt ist es ja so
wenn größere Teile der Wählerschaft sich
von den regierenden Parteien abwenden
und die größte Oppositionspartei davon
nicht gewinnt dann ist etwas im Gange
was was Fragen aufwirft und
selbstverständlich müssen sich
Regierungsparteien auch Fragen und sie
tun es ja ob man die richtigen Themen
hat um Themen ausgelassen werden ob man
die richtige Kommunikation wählt ob man
Entschlossenheit an den Tag legt die
Wählerinnen und Wähler erwarten oder ob
es zu viel Streit gibt das sind Fragen
die Regierungsparteien beantworten
müssen aber ich würde auch davor warnen
bei diesen Veränderungen von denen wir
sprechen wie ich es in der letzten Woche
in vielen Artikeln gelesen haben immer
danach zu fragen wer hat Schuld ist es
habe ich es ist Holz es ist Lindner ist
es März ich glaube damit greifen wir zu
kurz aber die Kommunikation das werden
Sie wahrscheinlich auch sehen so war
mäßig
deshalb ist schon die Frage ob nicht
vielleicht sogar der Zeit für in
Ordnungsruf des Bundespräsidenten
gekommen ist reden Sie mit dem
Parteivorsitzenden sagen die denen mal
macht's besser ich rede nicht jetzt neu
mit den Parteivorsitzenden sondern das
ist meine Routine in den letzten sechs
Jahren dass ich in unregelmäßigen
Zeitabständen nicht nur parteivorsitzen
auch Fraktionsvorsitzende manchmal auch
Abgeordnete denn der Fraktionen einlade
zu einem Gespräch in dem ich auch zu
ermitteln Versuch e wie die Stimmung ist
aber die Stimmung im Land ist eben auch
von ganz den anderen Dingen beeinflusst
die viel längerfristiger sind wir sind
das dürfen wir nicht ganz vergessen eine
Gesellschaft im Stress wir haben Krisen
hinter uns die Finanzkrise
2018/209 die Euro-Krise wir haben die
Debatte über flüchtlingszuwanderung wir
haben die Pandemie hinter uns und als
die Pandemie noch nicht ganz überwunden
war
begann der Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine das sind außergewöhnliche
Situationen da muss man Verständnis
dafür haben dass Menschen fragen haben
verunsichert sind aber ich bitte auch um
Verständnis für diejenigen die in
solchen Situationen Verantwortung tragen
und damit meine ich nicht nur den Bund
sondern vor allen Dingen auch die vielen
Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister und
Kommunalpolitiker die oft ehrenamtlich
vor Ort diese Verantwortung tragen
müssen und Reaktion ertragen müssen sie
sagen ein Land im Dauerstress das ist
ihr Befund und das gucken wir uns jetzt
noch mal kurz gebündelt an
das Vertrauen hat Schaden genommen auch
in uns selbst so räumt es der
Bundespräsident ein es ist in diesem
Jahr das Ansehen von Politik und
Politikern auf lange nicht gesehene
Umfragewerte gefallen die Partei des
Bundeskanzlers auf einem mehrjahres Tief
die AFD dagegen auf Allzeithoch und
erstmals vor der SPD
die Politiker auch Deutschlands höchster
haben gegen die Polarisierungen der
Gegenwart kein Mittel gefunden es kommen
härtere Jahre
raue Jahre auf uns zu obwohl Steinmeier
Fehler in seiner Russlandpolitik
eingeräumt hat das Vertrauen hat Schaden
genommen und die Kritik an der
Vergangenheit reist nicht ab ungewohnt
abweisend auch dieser Moment
DFB-Pokalfinale in Berlin
das Vertrauen hat Schaden genommen also
Herr Bundespräsident man muss sicherlich
beim DFB-Pokalfinale jetzt nicht
übermäßig sensibel sein aber so ein
bisschen ungewöhnlich war das wem gelten
solche Pfiffe wem galt das ihnen dem Amt
der ganzen politischen Klasse den da
oben das sind außergewöhnliche Umstände
bei einem Pokalfinale wo die wirklich
harten Fans beider Seiten zusammenkommen
und das stört eigentlich jeder von den
dfb-funktionären bis zur Politik
insofern das sollte uns nicht so sehr
beunruhigen ich schaue auf das was ich
tue ich bin viel unterwegs im Land
erfahre viel
Zustimmung erfahre dieses in vielen
Gesprächen und so weit Umfragen dass
wiedergeben können denke ich ist der
Bundespräsident jetzt auch nicht in
einer Situation sich beschweren zu
müssen aber sie gucken auf den Zustand
des Landes und sicherlich geht hier viel
Vertrauen geht hier auch Glaubwürdigkeit
im Moment ein Stück weit verloren die
Werte für die AFD auf jeden Falls wir
haben das gesehen im Einspieler sind auf
Rekordhöhe Regierung und Oppositionen
werfen sich gegenseitig vor
verantwortlich zu sein sie haben es
gerade schon angesprochen mit der Suche
nach den Schuldigen aber was ist ihre
Analyse woran liegt es das doch eine
Partei die in Teilen rechtsextreme so
Zulauf bekommt erstens natürlich dass
sie offenbar Fragen aufwirft bei denen
viele Menschen die Erwartungen nach
Antworten haben auch das spüre ich bei
meinen Gesprächen die ich während meiner
Ortszeiten drei Tage in einer kleinen
oder mittleren Stadt immer wieder höre
das sind Antworten die Politik finden
müssen was wird aus meinem Job wie
entwickelt sich die Inflation
positionieren wir uns im Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine richtig wie wird das
mit der Flüchtlingsbewegung an Europas
Grenzen das sind Fragen mit denen sich
Politik beschäftigen muss und da fehlen
die Antworten
gegen Russland gegen die Ukraine angeht
ganz sicher dass die Position die die
Bundesregierung einnimmt an der Seite
der Ukraine dafür zu sorgen dass sie
verteidigungsfähig bleibt als
angegriffene Nation dass das eine
Position ist die von der ganz großen
Mehrheit unseres Landes geteilt wird wir
brauchen darüber Debatten und ich habe
gerade auf den Evangelischen Kirchentag
in Nürnberg erlebt wie die Menschen auch
darum ringen eine verantwortliche
Position zu finden und ich glaube das
hat die Politik gezeigt bei der
Flüchtling lassen uns im Moment noch
dabei bleiben sie sagen die Politik muss
einfach die Antworten finden für die
Leute dann geht auch die AFD wieder
runter aber verfestigt sich da nicht
eigentlich gerade was Thüringen 34%
Brandenburg Sachsen 28 Prozent da wird
nächstes Jahr gewählt auch im Meppen
liegt die AFD jetzt bei 29% vor der SPD
ist das noch mit reinem Protest mit
Unzufriedenheit zu zu erklären oder wird
gerade bewusst die AFD das
antidemokratische diese nationalen Töne
gewählt weil es einfach der größte
Ausdruck des Protestes ist
ich glaube die Wähler tun das durchaus
bewusst viele tun es und sagen es ja
auch öffentlich um ihren Protest zu
äußern aber diejenigen die so
argumentieren den sage ich auch
jeder Wähler jede Wählerin übernimmt
Verantwortung für das was sie tut und
wenn Sie eine Partei stärkt die zur
Verrohung der Auseinandersetzung
beiträgt dann ist das auch die
Verantwortung eines mündigen Bürgers ich
glaube wir müssen einfach wieder lernen
den demokratischen Streit miteinander zu
führen ohne jeweils in Hass und Hetze
auszubrechen wir dürfen das Geschäft der
Angstmacher in dieser Gesellschaft nicht
noch weiter fördern sondern was wir
brauchen ist nicht eine Konjunktur der
Angstmacher sondern eine Konjunktur der
Problemlöser und das ist ja nicht so als
ob wir von denen keine hätten wenn wir
hier durch die Straßen an der A fahren
dann sehen sie überall danke Schilder
weil es so viel Hilfsbereitschaft aus
der ganzen Republik gibt gerade auch
junge Menschen die hierhergekommen sind
von Norddeutschland von der Küstenregion
hierher aus Bayern aus Franken die
geholfen haben wir haben doch ein großes
Reservoir glaube ich von Menschen die an
Problemlösung
interessiert sind sich daran orientieren
und deshalb ja die Umfragen sind
beunruhigend aber sie dürfen nicht dazu
führen dass wir jede kritische Frage
automatisch als Populismus und
Rechtsextremismus einordnen dann schauen
wir mal auf den Krieg in der Ukraine sie
haben es gerade angesprochen da trifft
sich ja die AFD jetzt ein Stück weit
auch mit den Linken beim Versuch sich
als Friedenspartei zu profilieren und
das könnte natürlich schon auch bei all
denen verfangen die jetzt Zweifel haben
auch immer mehr Waffen der richtige Weg
sind jetzt hat gestern die USA
zugestimmt Streumunition an die Ukraine
zu liefern das ist hier geächtet
wahrscheinlich auch mit guten Gründen
geächtet muss Deutschland sich dage
sperren oder haben sie muss dieses Land
das einfach nur verstehen was
träumenmunition angeht müssen Sie
verstehen ich bin der befangen ich war
derjenige der für unser Land die Ächtung
der Streumunition damals in Oslo
unterschrieben hat deswegen finde ich
Zeit für Waffen deshalb finde ich ist
die deutsche Position nach wie vor
richtig sich gegenströme Munition
auszusprechen aber sie kann in der
gegenwärtigen Situation der USA nicht in
den Arm fallen was die Waffen angeht so
glaube ich hatte hier eine
gesellschaftliche Diskussion darüber
stattgefunden es ist keine Frage an
welcher Seite wir in diesem Krieg stehen
muss ist es selten so klar wie hier wer
Täter wer Opfer ist und dass wir auf der
Seite des Opfers zu stehen haben und
dann ist die Frage wie kann ein solcher
Krieg zu Ende gehen er könnte morgen zu
Ende sein wenn Russland seine Soldaten
zurückschickt wenn die Ukraine ihre
Verteidigung einstellt oder wer dafür
sorgen dass sie nicht mehr Verteidigungs
fähig sind dann wird es das Ende der
Ukraine sein das ist der Unterschied auf
den immer wieder hinzuweisen ist sie
haben letztes Jahr persönlich eingeräumt
dass sie sich in Putin getäuscht haben
auch bei dem Versuch eben durch durch
Nähe Russland in irgendeiner Weise
bändigen zu können die Kritik an dieser
Strategie ist nicht verstummt und auch
nicht aus prominente Mund wir hören mal
diese führenden SPD-Politiker haben
jahrelang nicht nur sie auch
Personen aus der Union jahrelang sich im
Grunde etwas schön geguckt was mit
Moskau zusammen und wollten den Ernst
der Lage nicht sehen sondern immer wir
sind doch anständig wir begegnet ihnen
wie Partner und wir möchten da eine
Partnerschaft haben und Sie haben nicht
gesehen dass dieser Partner sich Schritt
für Schritt in einen Feind verwandelt
ihr Vorgänger jetzt noch immer April er
kritisiert sie nicht persönlich aber er
verweist natürlich auf die Merkel
Regierung auf die Kanzlerin den
Außenminister Steinmeier die SPD den
Pipelinebau braucht es am Ende
doch noch mal so was wie eine
grundsätzliche Aufarbeitung des
Verhältnisses zu Russland auch zur Frage
ob man zu spät warum man zu spät
umgesteuert hat es gibt ja sogar die den
Untersuchungsausschuss fordern ich habe
meinen Vorgänger nicht zu kritisieren
das ist seine Auffassung wenn sie danach
fragen ob wir eine Aufarbeitung brauchen
habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen
manches würde sich bei dieser
Aufarbeitung auch korrigieren nämlich
der Eindruck als ob das irgendwie eine
Art von Naivität oder gar liebesdienerei
gegenüber Russland gewesen sein das
Gegenteil ist doch der Fall der
Schlüssel sagte von Helsinki hat noch
jeder in Erinnerung damit begann vor 50
Jahren ein Prozess in dem man versucht
hat und nicht nur wir auch die
Amerikaner und viele andere in Europa so
etwas zu schaffen wie eine
Sicherheitsarchitektur unter der
Einbeziehung Russlands das hat nicht
funktioniert am Ende auch wir haben es
nicht hingekriegt und daraus müssen wir
unsere Schlüssel für die Zukunft ziehen
und das heißt eben bedauerlicherweise
Sicherheit in der Zukunft und Europa
wird nicht mehr eine gemeinsame
Sicherheit mit Russland sein sondern wir
werden uns voreinander Schützen mit
immensen Ausgaben für unsere
Verteidigungshaushalte um besseren
Schutz für Europa für die Allianz und
bessere besseren Schutz für unsere
eigene Bevölkerung in Deutschland zu
organisieren sie nennt Putin inzwischen
ein Feind
gleichwohl gibt es auch aus dem
Politiker Wolfgang ichtinger zum
Beispiel die den Haftbefehl für Putin
schädlich finden weil man vielleicht
noch mal mit ihm verhandeln müssen ist
ja was dran ja ich glaube das was
richtig ist was er jetzt gemacht wird
das Beweise gesammelt werden für die
Verantwortlichen in diesem Krieg und ich
hoffe dass wir in eine Situation kommen
werden in der mit diesen beweisen auch
für vor internationalen Institut schon
etwas anzufangen sein wird aber das
bedeutet eben auch dass wir auf das Ende
dieses Krieges schauen müssen und so
leid mir das tut aber auch in diesem
Interview muss ich Ihnen sagen ich
erkenne im Moment noch nicht die
Bedingungen in denen ich mir ein
Waffenstillstand vorstellen kann er
würde bedeuten zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
dass man den Landraub den Russland in
der Ukraine betreibt dass man diesen
Landraub belohnt insofern bleibt es
dabei Russland muss seine Truppen
zurückziehen und wir müssen Verständnis
dafür haben dass solange das nicht der
Fall ist die Ukraine die russischen
Truppen zurückzukämpfen versucht zwei
Tagen am Dienstag beginnt der
NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius von dem sich die
Ukraine auch eine klare Perspektive
erhofft für die Aufnahme in die NATO die
Türkei sogar ein bisschen überraschend
die Türkei Polen Litauen sind da ja
durchaus offen für die Aufnahme direkt
nach Ende des Krieges der amerikanischen
Präsident bremst etwas Deutschland ist
auch zurückhaltend
aber ohne Sicherheitsgarantien kann es
wenn man sie ernst nimmt in dem was sie
gerade gesagt hat kein Frieden geben in
der Tat und ich glaube gerade mit Blick
auf den NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius ich war
jetzt gerade da müssen wir ein paar
Dinge festhalten erstens was notwendig
ist ist ein Signal der Geschlossenheit
Geschlossenheit in der Allianz ist
unsere Stärke zum gegenwärtigen Zeit zum
zweitens dürfen wir davon ausgehen dass
die deutsche Rolle die wir einnehmen
sehr sehr geschätzt wird ich habe die
ganze Ostflanke der NATO in dem letzten
Jahr besucht es wird anerkannt dass
Deutschlands Truppenpräsenz in Baltikum
neben dem Briten zu der stärksten gehört
es wird anerkannt dass der deutsche
Beitrag nach Amerika auch mit und mit
die Unterstützung mit militärischen
Mitteln in der Ukraine der größte auf
dem europäischen Kontinent ist das alles
wird anerkannt und selbstverständlich
bin ich sehr dafür dass auf dem
NATO-Gipfel jetzt nach einer Möglichkeit
gesucht wird Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine passt das für Deutschland
werden am Ende auch Bundeswehrsoldaten
für die Ukraine sterben müssen in der
weitesten Konsequenz nein das sehe ich
nicht dass
versucht ja das ist der schwierige
Prozess in dem man sich jetzt im
Augenblick auf die Sicherheitsgarantien
zu bewegt welche Qualität sie haben
sollen um tatsächlich einen Mehrwert an
Sicherheit für die Ukraine zu bieten
daneben geht es auch darum die
Beziehungen zwischen der Ukraine und und
der NATO zu stärken auch dafür
wird überlegt ob man die gegenwärtigen
Beziehungen zu einem Ukraine naturat
hochstuft so letzte Frage noch der
Sommer bringt auch noch eine Fußball-WM
wie ist Ihre Planung werden sie nach
Australien nach Neuseeland reisen um die
deutschen Frauen zu unterstützen oder
ist das dann doch zu schlecht für den
co2-abdruck ich werde jede Form der
Unterstützung suchen und wünsche den
Frauen in Australien Neuseeland viel
viel Glück das ist eine Reise wird in
die Region das lasse ich zum
gegenwärtigen Zeitungen noch offen es
ist leider sehr sehr weit weg vielen
Dank Herr Bundespräsident vielen dank
ihnen für ihr Interesse am nächsten
Sonntag das nächste ZDF Sommer-
[Musik]